DR. JAMES GRIME: So we're
going to do a little
mathematical trick that I'm
hoping that people will like
and they'll try out on their
friends and family.
So let's do it.
We're going to write out
four-digit numbers.
So like this, right?
Now, you've got 3,485, but
we'll take it in turns.
So give me a four-digit
number.
You could just shout out four
digits if you want.
Go on.
BRADY HARAN: You want
one from me?
DR. JAMES GRIME: Yeah.
BRADY HARAN: 7,721.
DR. JAMES GRIME: 7,721.
And now I'll come up with a
different one, like 2,278.
Give me another.
BRADY HARAN: 1,891.
DR. JAMES GRIME: 1,891.
And I'll come up with another
one, like 8, 1--
something--
8.
And we're going to add
these together.
3,485, 7,721, 8, 1--
and 8, there you go.
So we see what that is.
Let's see what the answer is.
OK, so the final answer
is 23,483.
Now, before I started the trick,
I made a prediction on
that strip of brown paper.
Let's have a look.
Let's have a look at
my prediction.
If I open up my prediction,
it says, I predict 23,483.
And then I think what you're
meant to say here is tra-da!
Do you want to see
how to do it?
Shall we learn how to do it?
All right, and then people
can do it to
their friends, as well.
Did you notice I
started it off?
So I picked a number
to begin with.
Then you picked a number.
Then the number I picked
after you-- and
we took it in turns--
remember, I picked the digits
column by column add up to 9.
So 7 and 2, 7 and 2,
2 and 7, 1 and 8.
So these two together
are equal to 9,999.
The next two rows, I
did the same thing.
Can you see?
They add up to 9.
I had the 0 there when
you picked the 9.
And that's 9,999.
So the last four rows together
are going to be just shy--
well, this is just
shy of 10,000.
Add them together.
It's just shy of 20,000.
It's 2 short.
It's 19,998.
So I knew that the last four
numbers were 19,998.
So what I did to make
the prediction--
I had thought of this
in advance.
And then I added 20,000 to it,
which is quite easy to do,
because you put the digit
2 at the beginning.
And then because it's 2
less than 20,000, I
subtract the number 2.
So you put the digit
2 at the start.
And then you subtract
2 from the end.
And you can make your
prediction.
And you can look like a
mathematical genius.
MATT PARKER: Back to
the chosen card.
You're just not going
to get far enough.
But what you will do is you'll
take off, well, let's say 12.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, 10, 11, 12.
And then obviously you're going
to do the thing with,
oh, no, that's not it, it
didn't work, boo hoo.
The trick now is, instead of
putting these back on top, put
them underneath.